ce monde
[Musique]
le site de miley renvoie toujours
depping rassurant celui de mano si ces
deux miller reste encourageant non on
sera bientôt dessus et il ya une petite
complication tenter d'y atterrir serait
dangereux il ya une force
gravitationnelle colossal qui émane d'un
tel trou noir
la gravité de cette planète va ralentir
notre horloge décalage horaire j'ai eu
une fois que j'étais allé aux states
avec mes parents elle par exemple en
france il est 16h et dans le texas si
les genres 22h par exemple et bien à
chaque heure passée sur cette planète et
qui vaudra cette année sur notre vieille
terre ah ouais ok donc rien à voir en
fait ça c'est comme les années de chiens
donc du coup je propose ne peut pas
aller sur cette planète récupère
militants débrief à peine parti à peine
revenu on économise un temps dingue
si c'est la sphère de plusieurs années
j'aurai le temps d'étudier la gravité
oui je pense qu'on va avoir bien le
temps de faire plein de trucs largage au
revoir ranger au revoir et puis essayer
de vous maniez aussi parce que comme
nous c'est quoi cette même dix minutes
de retard ça nous foute dons directs a
donc tracé est clair
[Musique]
jorane ça fait des années que j'adore
combien d'années 23 ans ça fait 23 ans
qu'on se fait l'écho ici et qu'on se
fait bien chier donc merci
je t'ai vu dans cette prison et tué des
pertes une tu es tellement meilleur
disciple tu devrait aujourd'hui être à
mes côtés pour sauver le monde
ma place je vais la prendre entre vous
et les habitants de quotas
personne peut sauver gotham ok c'est bon
les gars vous pouvez préparer le feu là
quand une foire est devient trop sauvage
purification par le feu me semble
inévitable et moi on est préparé j'avais
dit préparer le fola c'est demain le
monde assistera avec horreur à
l'autodestruction de ses plus grands
films rase en fait là ils ont ils ont
lancé le feu carrément j'avais dit
préparé et du coup en fait nous on est
deux dans la maison donc rien et
personne n'empêchera le retour de
l'harmonie cette fois c'est chaud non
oui c'est d'un incendie sûrement qu'ils
génèrent d'achat l'heure on se casse
ouais parce que là c'est bien vu parce
que là vraiment ça craque de partout
donc non non mais sérieux voulait pas
aller parler dehors parce que là il ya
des flammes et un truc qui s'effondre
donc on la joue c'est que vous avez déjà
attaqué cc pour l'achever de tout sens
propre mais elle est cette fois aucun de
l'idéaliste malavisé nano avec nous
alors un skype un petit sky tranquille à
la maison ou en face time lorsque
quelqu'un veut parer la route à la vraie
justice tu t'approches de lui
par surprise et tu lui poignard de coeur
ok donc là il s'est pris une poutre dans
la gueule on reste là si vous voulez
hein c'est vous le boss mais là là vous
êtes parti ok ok elle merci d'avoir
prévu donc tourner d'yvan parce qu'on
est garée devant
donc on tracer
[Musique]
m
il ya quelque chose qui me gonfle
vraiment on a quelqu'un qui joue faux
par millions moi c'est moi je t'ai
n'importe quoi whiplash
il nous faut un policier qui n'a besoin
ni de manger ni de dormir doté d'une
grande puissance de feu et des réflexes
adéquat
mes chers collègues j'ai l'honneur et le
plaisir de vous présenter le champion de
la sécurité publique des 209 yes c'est
mon invention je suis chef de projet sur
le truc donc écho dépisteurs 209 est un
robot policiers entièrement autonome est
entièrement conçue par mois dont il est
à l'heure actuelle programmé pour qu'il
tienne c'est pas cool parce que là ils
allés applaudir je pense le 209 occupera
à notre avis une place essentielle dans
l'arsenal militaire de la prochaine
décennie
monsieur qui ne braque et votre arme de
façon menaçante suivre comme si sa vie
passe second tour
z'avez qu'à way you lie la jetée l'arbre
matelas posé par terre
en fait là comme c'est une démo j'ai dit
qu'il met pas de munitions
oui je n'étais pas tout seul tout seul
non plus un y avait quand même eux qui
m'aidaient et puis il a le rappelle
qu'il a quand même jetés larmes et
normalement il faut la poser par terre
voilà on appelle une ambulance
oui ça lui sert à rien mais niel voilà
vous pouvez vous abonner
autre truc et puis si vous cliquez là
vous pouvez voir l'épisode 1 de ce que
vous venez de voir
je suis désolé en fait j'avais pas prévu
qu'on m'écoute du coup je suis pas
habitué je suis un peu pris au dépourvu
mais s'allonge ici ouais et au revoir
couplant